was ist besser als frische knusprige
Nachos loaded Nachos und die haben es
wirklich in sich unsere Nachos machen
wir selbst aus maisistortillas einfach
Tortillas halbieren und in kleine
nachoecken schneiden dann nehmen wir uns
unsere Nachos und geben Sie einfach in
die Friteuse das Schöne bei loaded
Nachos ist man kann sie toppen mit allem
worauf man Lust hat ich mache eine
kesosoße dafür gebe ich 50 g Butter in
Topf und lasse sie schmilzen hieren
breite ich mir ein bisschen Hackfleisch
an jetzt gebe ich ein paar Gewürze dran
räucherpaprika cayenpfeffer und schöne
Schare Chili Frise Salz und schön anbrab
zu den 50 g Butter rühre ich jetzt 50 g
Mehl mit ein so erhalten wir eine
Mehlschwitze wunderbar und darauf gebe
ich jetzt Milch die Milch rühre ich
langsam ein und hier rein geben wir
jetzt einen ordentlichen Block
Schmelzkäse schaut euch mal an wie
wunderschön cremig unser käso ist jetzt
nehmen wir uns zwei gute Handvoll von
unseren Nachos dann folgt unser KESO
boah junge nicht zu viel wir wollen die
Nachos noch sehen okay doch mehr unser
gewürztes Hackfleisch ein bisschen
avocadreme ein paar Tomaten weiße
Zwiebel Jalapenos und zum Abschluss noch
mal KESO junge